we continue our Donnie Osmond week here
on 8 news now I had the privilege of
sitting down at the Las Vegas icon and
he talked about what he calls a roller
coaster of a career certainly as we know
the road to success is often paved with
mistakes and failures and Donnie says
it's what we learned from them that make
us who we are
there's life expectancy in any career
any job any business any company it's a
bell curve
and uh
at some point in time you reach the top
of that Bell
and it's going to go down it's
inevitable
every company deals with it but what are
you going to do at that top you're in re
reinvent another Bell
Donny Osmond is very candid about the
struggles he's faced as a performer and
the ups and downs he's experienced in
his career and if I could talk to the 20
year old Donnie again
which was the worst decade of my life
because it's where I lost everything my
career finances I had nothing absolutely
nothing and a family tried to support a
family
I would say to him lighten up taking his
own advice to heart he says sure there
are plenty of things that can go wrong
on stage now he just has to laugh at all
so the other night
I was singing Moon River Moon River
started choking
and
as a youngster I would have just
panicked
so you know what I did
I stopped the show
and I said well that didn't work
everybody starts laughing that sort of
humility comes from humble beginnings
and learning lessons from those who came
before him like the king of rock and
roll himself the door opens up Elvis
walks in
and he says Hi everybody I'm Elvis you
know just like what he said and I'm
thinking to myself yeah we know that
everybody knows that
but what affected me and it really
affected me a lot
is that I realize this guy that I saw
the night before 24 hours before
the king of rock and roll is just a
normal person
Johnny also told me it was a fan who
reminded him just how important some of
his older songs are including poppy love
he says he didn't sing it for a long
time until someone reminded him it was
part of her memories now it's in every
show